kindy à 2015
c'est plus qu'un film c'est une aventure
télévisuelle hors norme pour laquelle
nous avons choisi de prendre le temps de
mieux comprendre pour mieux aider
pendant quatre ans nos équipes vont
s'installer en guinée conakry un pays
francophone d'afrique de l'ouest
parmi les plus pauvres du monde pour
accompagner le travail d'hommes et de
femmes qui s'engagent sur le terrain
jusqu'en 2015 vous allez vivre au rythme
de la ville de kindia et de sa région
les habitants y ont de graves problèmes
de pollution d'accès à l'eau potable à
l'éducation à la santé
kindia une ville de 250000 habitants qui
concentre en un même endroit tous les
grands enjeux du développement
alors ne vous proposons de relever un
défi améliorer d'ici 2015 les conditions
de vie des populations aider à la
construction d'écoles aménager des
sources soigner les femmes et les
enfants
protéger l'environnement année après
année vous allez pouvoir participer
directement et en temps réel aux projets
et devenir si vous le souhaitez des
acteurs du développement pour tenir ce
pari
les projets sont financés par les ong
partenaires et le fonds de dotation
kindia plus à tout moment vous pouvez
aider par vos suggestions vos idées et
contribuer par vos dons au faou kindia
plus 4 en quatre films poursuivre les
projets rendre compte des réussites et
des obstacles rencontrés
ensemble nous avons jusqu'en 2015 pour
réussir
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]
on
on pourrait croire à une malédiction
surian pony ce vaste au bout de mangrove
sur la côte de guinée une zone humide
dévastés par le feu la des friches
autrefois ici le climat était doux les
poissons frais y est sous les
palétuviers ces arbres aux pieds dans
l'eau mais ayant pony pour survivre le
paysan guinéen est obligé de détruire ce
qui le fait vivre
[Musique]
raser la mangrove pour récolter l'or
blanc de la côte africaine le sel
chaque année à la saison sèche il arrive
sur la zone éparpillés par petits
groupes loin de tout dans des campements
de fortune
[Musique]
sur yon pony ils seraient plus de 5000
en comptant les familles
la plus grande concentration en afrique
5000 força volontaires venus un mois ou
deux pour faire bouillir la saumure de
l'autre est concentrée en selle sur de
grands bacs en fer blanc
c'est un très très dur
ouais avec le soleil et avec le fis
c'est très dur mais comme il n'ya pas de
notre travail avant que tu vas voulait
quelqu'un qui sort aux familles en deuil
[Musique]
mohamed sylla à 54 ans il est guinéen
mais ici tout le monde l'appelle
sénégalais parce qu'il a longtemps vécu
à dakar s'il veut du cash de quoi payer
les dépenses de la famille alors tous
les ans au mois de mars sénégalais les
siens doivent revenir ici souffrir
quelques semaines à yang pony gratter le
sol chargés en selle par les grandes
marées laver cette terre à l'eau de mer
dans les tanks et ses grands filtre en
feuilles de palmier pour récupérer la
saumure je n'ai pas en vivant une série
tout le reste c'est le gazon et coûte
cher
ouais alors si tu n'es pas travailler
comme fils ne peut pas étudier alors il
faut que nous on souffre mais on veut
pas que notre enfant sous le précédent
mandat
l'étape suivante est la plus pénible la
plus dangereuse aussi quand il faut
faire bouillir ce selles liquides la
saumure brûlé dégage du chlorure
d'hydrogène un gaz toxique qui pique les
yeux soulève les poumons empoisonne
l'atmosphère en guinée le cultivateur de
sel à une espérance de vie d'une
quarantaine d'années dix ans de moins
que celle du paysan ordinaire
à 4500 kilomètres de là des français ont
décidé de refuser cette fatalité et de
se battre pour leurs collègues africains
l'initiateur de cette solidarité avec la
guinée c'est alain courtel y les
paludiers et récoltes sont celles dans
le paysage idyllique des marais salants
de guérande en bretagne à une heure de
route de nantes
j'ai toujours autant de plaisir et
malgré que ce soir des gestes répétitifs
et où j'ai l'impression que c'est
toujours la première fois puis là en
l'occurrence c'est pratiquement la
première récolte de la saison donc c'est
un petit peu un moment magique où on en
est je sais pas j'ai l'impression d'être
d'être vivant ici c'est toujours un peu
aller coûte de la nature du nuage qui
veut à venir
donc ça met les sens en éveil bon je
trouve que c'est un métier fabuleux et
puis aussi le sentiment de produire un
produit de qualité donc voilà ça donne
du sens à une vie alain courtel a fondé
l'association universel une ong pour
aider les paysans du sel partout dans le
monde et notamment en guinée
pourquoi on s'investit comme ça
je suis pas je pense que c'est d'une
part parce que c'est quand même la
grosse précarité c'est quand même
les gens qui sont dans des situations
économiques très difficiles
donc voilà on a envie de on a envie
d'essayer de voir si on peut pas donner
un coup de main quad est d'améliorer ses
conditions de vie et de travail ayant
pony en guinée les hommes sont menacés
la nature aussi sénégalais doit
alimenter son foyer 24 heures sur 24
un feu qui s'est éteint ce sont des
heures de selle en moins la hantise du
producteur il faut du bois en permanence
il n'y a pas de bois le bois est fini
car oui tout est récoltée et si on
coupait tout même à là où on trouve le
bois c'est l'un là bas ça dépasse un
clown et peut-être des kilomètres pour
obtenir 1 kg de sel il faut couper et
brûlé trois kilos de bois chaque année
en guinée cinquante mille tonnes de sel
sorte de la mangrove soit 150 mille
tonnes de bois qui partent en fumée
dans cet environnement très fragile la
coupe dépasse aujourd'hui les capacités
du milieu là bas il n'y a plus rien tout
est et coupez-les ya deux ou trois ans
comme il n'y a plus de bois près du
campement on vient jusqu'ici mais c'est
du bois vert trop jeune en principe il
faudrait couper des arbres plus grands
il n'y a plus rien vous savez que c'est
la destruction de la nature la coupe
abusive de bois oui c'est ça oui
mais pourquoi vous le faites alors parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres moyens
à ce moment il ya peu reconnaît un toit
là il ya du bois encore mais pour
combien de temps je dire c'est vrai que
tout le monde en est conscient mais me
ils savent que bon ils vont encore
piocher dans la réserve
de mangrove mais leurs enfants
rompue rien à voler quoi la mangue à
d'autres fonctions que de faire chauffer
de la saumure
c'est le poumon c'est le poumon de la
planète
ces forêts tropicales c'est extrêmement
riche pour le milieu pour la
reproduction des poissons pour plein de
plein de choses
donc c'est vraiment un combat qu'il faut
qu'il faut continuer de façon à protéger
le patrimoine de l'humanité
les paludiers de guérande ont trouvé une
solution pour produire du sel en afrique
sans détruire la mangrove ni ruiner la
santé des paysans
une idée a priori toute simple des
bâches plastiques l'action du soleil et
du vent plutôt que la dévastation de la
machette et du feu un système met au
point il ya près de 25 ans lors d'un
voyage au bénin un autre pays d'afrique
de l'ouest
je me rappelle quand on était sur la
lagune béninoise on galérait à vouloir
faire des marais salants qui ne
marchaient pas parce que trop de
ce n'était pas imperméable et c'est donc
là il y avait des crabes
c'était compliqué donc c'est là qu'on a
eu l'idée d'amener les premiers
cristallise war en plastique pour
démontrer aux productrices de celle du
bénin qu'on pouvait faire du ces avec le
soleil pour elle c'était c'était une vue
de l'esprit quoi et on a posé cette
bâche me rappelle dans le matin dans une
plaine dans le village de laon où la
plaine de l'angola et
est allé le matin celle l'après-midi et
donc dans toutes les toutes les
productrices des maîtresses femmes sont
pointés autour du cristal is war tu
cèdes ged j'ai fait un bon c'est bon là
c'est le c'est le soleil qui fait cadeau
là c'est lui là et ça marche
on a récolté le premier celle solaire du
bénin et donc sans tourner vers moi pour
m'applaudir donc moi j'étais quand même
un peu un peu gêné que j'étais et j'ai
vu un nombre pas moi qu'il faut
applaudir c'est le soleil et je me
rappelle tout cela symboliquement train
d'applaudir le soleil c'est c'est des
moments de deux extraordinaires
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est super gratifiant de pouvoir aider
des gens et d'en retirer des
satisfactions personnelles sont à quoi
ça sert la vie vont on passe pas la vie
comme ça simplement à consommer non je
pense qu'il ya plus que ça il faut
s'intéresser à ce qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer donc voilà je crois que et
puis on retourne à ses souvenirs ses ces
regards de complicité de donc tout ça et
est une nourriture et star moteur donc
voilà on
on en ressort grandi mois ces deux
sentiments anglais depuis les années où
je travaille en afrique
sam a bonifié sa masse à donner du sens
à ma vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en guinée le grand défi c'est
l'éducation
65% des guinéens ne savent ni lire ni
écrire dans les campagnes la situation
est dramatique 9 euros sur 10 sont
illettrés les pires chiffres d'afrique
de l'ouest
c'est pourquoi l'unicef va intervenir en
brousse à trois heures de piste de
kindia la préfecture de télimélé une
zone très enclavées où l'éducation est
en déshérence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la friterie
[Applaudissements]
des pics repos attention
l'école du petit village de ma b est
typique des établissements de la
campagne dîner n patriotique et
autoritaire un peu comme la france
rurale des années 50
ici les promesses de l'indépendance
n'ont pas vraiment été tenus les moyens
sont dérisoires
le bâtiment délabré tout a été construit
par les villageois eux mêmes
kadiatou égaler le nombre il y a deux à
suis également allé à 1,2 à l'école de
ma b contre 124 élèves pour trois
classes
c'est à peine la moitié des enfants du
village les autres traînent dehors ou
sont partis travailler aux champs avec
leurs parents une situation intolérable
aux yeux de julien harness un franco
britannique de 46 ans le représentant de
l'unicef en guinée conakry
les défis de l'éducation c'est un peu
dans les grandes villes mais en majorité
c'est dans des villages comme celui ci
où il n'y a pas d'enfants qui ont
terminé l'école depuis des années et
presque pâle fille qui sont qui sont à
l'école si on doit changer ça c'est ici
[Musique]
le projet de l'unicef construire des
écoles dignes de ce nom dans la
préfecture de télimélé il y a urgence
aujourd'hui seulement 7 % des filles
achève l'école primaire
ce sont les pires chiffres du pays
quatre fois moins que la moyenne
nationale
c'est le cas de la petite aïssatou sept
ans elle aurait bien aimé rejoindre ses
camarades en cp cette année mais elle a
dû rester sur le pas de la porte de
l'école aujourd'hui comme tous les jours
aïssatou reste auprès de sa maman
madame barry qui n'envoie aucun de ses
enfants en classe kadiatou l'aîné c'est
elle qui met pour la fabrication d'huile
de palme tout seul je ne pourrai jamais
y arriver nous elle vient aussi m'aider
aux travaux des champs et elle
m'accompagne au marché pour aller vendre
nos produits
et pendant ce temps-là binta elle peut
rester à la maison et s'occuper des plus
petits comme aïssatou je regrette
beaucoup qu'elle n'aille pas à l'école
cela aurait été bon pour nous tous cas
pas mais moi je ne peux pas assumer les
dépenses d'une scolarité le matériel les
uniformes et tout ça j'arrive à peine à
nourrir et habiller mahfal et le peu que
nous gagnons c'est uniquement parce que
mes grands films ed
le destin d'aïssatou baril est déjà
écrit elle fera comme ses grandes soeurs
une enfance puis une adolescence
consacrée au travail
l'aînée des filles barie 15 ans n'a
jamais été en cours de sa vie la cadette
présent à arrêter après le cp
aujourd'hui elles sont de corvée de
lessive l'école pour elle les canes
immense regret quand on me parle en
français je ne peux pas répondre je ne
comprends pas parce que je n'ai pas
appris quand on me demande un service
dans cette langue
je ne peux pas le rendre il ya beaucoup
de choses qui nous font regretter de ne
pas avoir été à l'école cela fait une
grande différence entre nous et celle de
nos copines qui fréquentent l'école
nous nous sommes complexé elles elles
ont des parents qui ont les moyens et
nous nos parents n'en n'ont pas
la journée est loin d'être finie pour
les filles baril après le linge c'est la
corvée d'eau pour la maison aujourd'hui
les deux soeurs vont aider leur maman a
préparé de l'huile de palme qu'elle
pourra vendre au marché en fin de
semaine du petit commerce un peu
d'agriculture pour un revenu très
précaire ya un choix à chaque famille
qui est est ce que on demande à nos
enfants le travail ou dans les champs
pour qu'on puisse se nourrir ou est-ce
qu'on va investir dans le futur
ils vont probablement décidé de retirer
leurs enfants de l'école où ils vont
même pas les envoyer
donc il ya cet aspect là il ya aussi
l'aspect qui est plutôt sociale c'est à
dire que les défis se marient ou donner
naissance à des enfants à des achats ces
jeunes 15 15 16 ans et sam est sûre ça
peut ça peut couper une éducation
le seul espoir d'un avenir différent
pour la petite aïssatou baril c'est le
projet de l'unicef et pour couvrir les
besoins de la zone de télimélé le défi
est immense
parvenir à scolariser 80 % des enfants
de la région
départ vers un autre village encore plus
loin en brousse bape et petit hameau
d'éleveurs et d'agriculteurs poehl où
l'on cultive un peu de riz et de manioc
l'école une bâtisse de tôles et de terre
séchée elle est censée couvrir les
besoins des cinq entre villages de la
vallée
[Musique]
ici aussi les enfants sont nombreux à
s'en passer en cours
et les conditions d'apprentissage d'une
médiocrité extrême dans la classe de
cm1-cm2 de monsieur iata le directeur de
l'école le cours de géométrie
ces systèmes d les cercles par exemple
voici on ferait une feuille rempli pour
aller vite on met un petit trou au
milieu et all viennent de l'autre côté
un peu haut mais le deuxième c'est
compris après omet d'année
[Musique]
à côté chez le cp de madame diallo en
poste depuis un an
ce n'est pas mieux
m
un livre pour 10 élèves des enfants de 6
à 12 ans dans la même classe
pas facile d'avoir des résultats dans
ces conditions cela fait plus de dix ans
que l'école de bap et n'a pas envoyé
d'élèves au collège
aucun n'a réussi l'examen d'entrée
emmener des élèves jusqu'au collège ça
va être difficile car les enfants
un pas de livres pour travailler moi
pour qu'ils apprennent pas je fais du
marqueur des chansons ville car ils
n'ont aucun document avec lesquelles il
pourrait réviser et à la maison personne
ne peut les aider car leurs parents sont
analphabètes biblis à à 9 ans elle est
douée elle travaille dur
pourtant cela fait trois ans qu'elle
redouble son cp bilguissa ni pour rien
cela fait des années que le village
attend un maître d'école pour assurer le
ce1 et de ce2 mais rien ne vient pas
d'instituteur alors faute de mieux
bilgi ça reste encore préparatoire une
situation décourageante
alors que sa mère fait tous les
sacrifices pour lui payer l'école
l'investissement d'une famille très
pauvre réduit à néant ou presque
moi même je regrette beaucoup de ne pas
être allé à l'école quand je reçois du
courrier confidentiel de la part de
proches
je suis obligée de demander à quelqu'un
du village de me faire la lecture
une fête très embarrassant car je suis
obligé de partager des secrets que
j'aurais voulu garder pour moi laissé
seul à l'ignorance c'est pour éviter le
même destin ma fille que je veux qu'elle
étudie
cette absence de professeurs qui bloque
son parcours scolaire
ça nous inquiète sur cela mais si cela
continue va se décourager je sais
qu'elle se pose déjà des questions pour
la suite de ses études il dit ça toi ça
t'énerve il est de voir rétrograder
comme sa faute de professeurs moi je
sais que j'ai le niveau pour aller de
l'avant
alors cette interruption ça m'exaspère
comme l'état n'en vois toujours pas
d'instituteur pour le cours élémentaire
et les villageois ont essayé d'en
recruter 1 par leurs propres moyens
faute de place dans l'école ils ont même
construit une classe un peu plus haut
dans le village c'est monsieur iata le
directeur de l'école qui nous montre le
hangar la cahute qui devait abriter le
nouveau cours pas facile d'attirer un
prof dans des conditions aussi précaires
[Applaudissements]
les banques comme pour les élèves
le cassis et viennent de mettre les
cahiers ici ou bien l'arbre a déçu les
crises on est cuit comme ça on peut
vraiment saignée dans ces conditions
c'est pas tellement facile mais on est
contraint de le faire avant qu'on ne
gagne le prix d'en bas ici à chaque fois
quand la pluie tombe les houles de la
pluie d'un mois ne fait pas puisque ça
prouve
le prof supplémentaire n'est jamais venu
de toute façon le village n'aurait pas
pu le payer longtemps
la récolte de riz a été trop mauvaise
cette année pour encourager des
enseignants 1 100 plaintes et ici c'est
bon c'est pas c'est pas très facile
parce que bon le ils vont réguler comme
si on ne sait pas grand chose ici
si eux ils ont des enfants ou s'il veut
avoir accès à la santé ou s'il veut que
leurs enfants vont collèges etc
c'est c'est dur pour eux prof en milieu
rural ça n'a rien d'une sinécure partagé
la vie rustique de la brousse en
décourage plus d'un
afin de réussir son projet l'unicef va
donc travailler avec l'état guinéen
essayer de maintenir ou d'attirer des
enseignants compétents et motivés
grâce à la promesse de nouvelles
infrastructures et de meilleures
conditions de travail
un pari difficile pour garantir en font
aux enfants de la région
le droit à une scolarité normale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kindia
250000 habitants la deuxième ville de
guinée
une démographie galopante
quinze mille nouveaux arrivants chaque
année issues de l'exode rural
mais l'équipement urbain ne suis pas
kindia n'arrivent plus à faire face
[Musique]
et
depuis l'arrivée du plastique dans les
années 80 l'afrique connaît une
pollution sans précédent
[Musique]
le service public de ramassage est
défaillant
[Musique]
kindia croule sous ces déchets la ville
s'empoisonne
[Musique]
les autorités locales sont submergés par
le phénomène
le docteur mamadou dramé et le maire de
kindia depuis 1995
cet ancien pharmacien c'est qu'il va
falloir trouver des solutions pour
assainir la ville mais par où commencer
ce n'est pas le sol du comptoir ici il y
a dans la ville de tous comme ça de
moindre importance parfois mais des
dépotoirs quand même sauvage et qui sont
pas traitées ça quelle conséquence
d'avoir des dépotoirs sauvages comme ça
peu partout en ville assurent les deux
maladies infectieuses la première chose
c'est d'être tout ce qui est une maladie
infectieuse le choléra tout mais
puissante et ville et maladies tous ceux
qui aiment vers intestinale et le fait
que ces zones soient là là il ya des
odeurs qui émanent qui font des
problèmes respiratoires
on a beau dire le prendre
l'assainissement c'est un problème
d'abord comportement car c'est vrai mais
aussi est un principe moyens il faut le
l'assainissement le traitement des
ordures est très cher
la commune de kindia ne peut pas faire
face aux besoins un seul camion benne en
état de marche et 5 éboueurs pour toute
la ville et ses 250 mille habitants
alors le maire s'est tourné vers
coopération atlantique guinée 44 une ong
nantaise implanté depuis 20 ans dans la
région est spécialisé dans le
développement local
grégoire gailly un français de 35 ans
coordonne les actions sur le terrain il
n'est 44 c'est une association qui
intervient en guinée depuis maintenant
plus de vingt ans et qui a été créée par
le département 44 la loire atlantique
c'est une association de solidarité
internationale
elle vise à faire travailler ensemble
des acteurs français des acteurs
guinéens dans des projets où on essaye
d'améliorer bon les conditions de vie
des populations c'est les termes un peu
classique mais la réalité la finalité
c'est bien ça l'objectif c'est vraiment
de travailler sur le développement local
le développement des activités
localement qui permet d'améliorer les
conditions de vie des populations pour
régler le problème des déchets rien ne
se fera sans l'adhésion des populations
la priorité de l'ol j'ai nantaise
sensibiliser les habitants pour changer
les comportements
diarra et diallo est la sociologue de
guinée 44
elle va sur le terrain au contact des
familles au coeur des quartiers
vous le disiez palace et hautbois samedi
à lire parce que il ya juste le battre
au derrière et qu'on ya la rivière qui
est
juste à côté certains passent à me
demander aux ménages qui sont par là
comment ils se débarrassent de leurs
déchets ménard a dit gainey
nogué sarraf aussi le rôle de samassa a
les moyens
donc la mecque est tenue vendredi par
ailleurs gunnar à sa poursuite
parce que pour ces armes et à l'appuyer
n'a pas à rendre dingue idées aux
voleurs et tant mieux ça ira fossé roy
hibbert ira fouiller une à obtenir le
poignet del lavoro fille est tellement
proche de la normale mais ça c'est à
lourdes utilisées par les syndicats ou
les déchets ça un peu traîné parce que
tout simplement chez nous à tu sais les
gens il ya des choses et ses diverses et
la fête du gouvernement moi je n'ai rien
à faire donc c'est la mairie et la
pousse à louvain le gouverneur il est là
pour ça pour que la vie soit rob lowe
personne ne se dit bah moi aussi je dois
participer et c'est ça qu'il faut
changer je nous vois donc c'est déjà
faire beaucoup d'animations aussi aller
de porte à porte pour discuter avec les
gens c'est vraiment quand tu le fais
c'est un travail très lent donc il faut
vraiment aller à leur rythme et surtout
ne pas lâcher parce que moi je me dis à
chaque fois que dès que tu lâches
vois tu deviens un niveau beaucoup plus
bas que le niveau que tu avais à rome
pour toucher l'ensemble des habitants de
kindia le porte à porte n'est pas
suffisant il faut communiquer
massivement
mais ici pas de télévision locale
l'internet trop cher ou défaillants et
une seule radio rurale alors coopération
atlantique guinée 44 subventionne des
spectacles de rue pour sensibiliser une
population à 64 cents
analphabète
[Applaudissements]
quand on a des troupes de théâtre qui
font des spectacles sur l'eau et
l'assainissement et que on voit que le
message passe grâce à ça ou les jeux
publics à la radio on sent quand même
qu'à une prise de conscience on se rend
bien compte que il ya une amélioration
donc là dessus on est content grégoire
pourquoi est ce que tu t'es lancé dans
la coopération de développement
moi j'ai eu la chance - chine et dans la
banlieue parisienne la banlieue plutôt
aisée et je suis issu d'une famille
voilà qu a pas de problème de l'argent
globalement familles nombreuses
éducation très judéo chrétienne avec le
souci de l'autre et d'aider son prochain
on a eu la chance en famille de partir à
l'expatriation pendant trois ans au
nigeria donc ça forcément ça va
évidemment marqué et finalement j'ai
même orienté mes études versailles
j'étais ingénieur agronome et je me suis
spécialisée en agronomie tropicale et je
me suis retrouvé dans cette formation
qui en plus prenez comme exemple la
plupart du temps des projets de
développement en afrique et qui du coup
montrer qu'en 50 ans de coopération
c'est vrai que les résultats n'étaient
pas à la hauteur mais fallait pas non
plus noircir le tableau il ya quand même
des résultats on aide d des personnes
soit de la société civile soit des
collectivités soit de l'état à faire
bien leur travail
[Musique]
à kindia le service public de ramassage
des ordures est déficient jusqu'à
l'absurde à la périphérie de la ville
le maire tient à nous montrer la
décharge municipale l'endroit est
difficilement accessible
un grand trou totalement vide
la ville croule sous les déchets mais la
décharge publique reste vierge
aucun camion poubelle ne vient déposer
ses ordures ici le toux se prolonge
jusque jusqu'au niveau là bas là où il
ya la maison en briques la future cette
année qu'il ya de l'espace a encore pour
longtemps
mais aujourd'hui c'est ça faire c'est
très compliqué est-ce qui est pas un
autre problème qui est que en fait les
déchets sont vendus il ya un trafic de
déchets surtout que la vienne trafic de
déchets recyclables et qui fait et qui
est dangereux
pourquoi pas s'il ya pas de pluie c'est
du tout qui est 28 vous devrez trouver
aujourd'hui chez les maraîchers des
piles dallaire le champ en fait au lieu
d'aller à la décharge
les éboueurs revendre les déchets non
triés de la ville aux paysans qui les
utilisent comme fertilisant pour
cultiver les fruits et les légumes
c'est moins cher que du fumier animal
mais ça coûte tout de même l'équivalent
de 8 euros la benne ici les ordures
c'est l'engrais du pauvre astoria sylla
et le porte parole des cultivateurs de
kindia
[Musique]
c'est dave labrecque parce que quand tu
mets ça donne ça pousse
si vous voyez la lettre se voit ses
laitues ça pousse quand tu vois ses sept
au match s'approchait normalement
ça pousse c'est sûr mais pour utiliser
les déchets comme compost
les paysannes sont obligés de faire un
premier tri grossier elle même le tout à
mains nues sans aucune protection
rappel font ça qu'est-ce qu'elles
craignent comme le blé su encore en
faisant ce travail tu peux te couper
avec des lames de rasoir et il ya même
des seringues usagées
il y a beaucoup d'objets dangereux si tu
te pique avec ça tu risques plein de
maladies comme le tétanos pour éviter de
prendre autant de risques et moins
polluer leurs terres les maraîchers sont
prêts à payer le chargement de déchets
deux fois plus cher à condition
d'obtenir des ordures organique
complètement trier aujourd'hui la
population
la pollution n'est pas encore dense mais
comme on conduit la foule lui avoir lié
ses on trouve pas de solution par
rapport à ça la génération future et nos
le trafic est connu des autorités qui
ont trop longtemps laissé faire mais le
maire de kindia a son idée pour essayer
d'y mettre un terme
aujourd'hui c'est tout et même mélange
de plastique de métal de piler pouces et
un motif qu'elle a mais malgré tout cela
dit à des gens qui prennent donc c'est
vrai que le marché existe mais
aujourd'hui il faut organiser le marché
il faut l'organiser en amont il faut
expliquer à la population qui vient
aujourd'hui la l1 mais les activités
génératrices de revenus et faire la
sorte que les gens s'intéressent à ces
âges sur les plateformes est en ville
pour faire les puits notre travail c'est
transformer ce cercle vicieux à cette
battue
pour appuyer l'intuition du maire
coopération atlantique guinée 44 propose
d'impliquer la genèse de kindia
le principe est simple les jeunes vont
collecter les déchets directement chez
l'habitant et laiteries pour les
revendre aux maraîchers c'est un service
payant qui doit permettre aux jeunes des
quartiers de gagner de l'argent aux
maraîchers d'obtenir un compost plus
propres et aux habitants de ne plus
polluer leur ville je vous avez ramassé
comme déchets la ménagère way
ensuite le second sac c'est le plastique
c'est une d'énergie d'accord ça c'est
les gens qui font tricher e sellem femme
là qui trie on les a appris à faire ça
nous faciliter la tâche à faire ici à
des pratiques et dans l'autre mélangez y
en a ici vous il faisait comme en avant
pour les ordures
bon avant nous ont amené la joie dit
dans les yeux dans les bas fonds où
aller j'étais là-bas les vous vous payez
bon nous sommes abonnés ici d'accord la
bonne on a beau nous évitera payer c'est
combien la chambre quand même cette
misère c'est plus franc
70 centimes d'euro par mois après la
collecte le groupe de jeunes rejoint le
centre de tri
une plateforme en béton financé par la
coopération avec l'agglomération
nantaise
une expérience piloté par guinée 44 pour
la ville de kindia ici les plastiques
les métaux et les autres détritus sont
séparés pour recycler ce qui peut l'être
et récupérer les déchets organiques pour
les m'arracher grégoire est venu voir
sur place l'avancée dû projet
[Musique]
allez
et pas une fête pour un quartier manque
la femme dans tous les quartiers autour
il ya tous les anciens dépotoirs
sauvages qui normalement doit et u18 20
mètres bourg ou l'uci si on arrive à
avoir des dispositifs qui fonctionne de
manière économique comme dans d'autres
pays au mali au sénégal il a marche ici
on pense que c'est possible
on sait que ça sera pas du jour au
lendemain parce qu'il faut d'abord que
le service s'améliore donc tout le
travail c'est d'essayer d'accompagner
accompagner les dynamiques en essayant
de repérer les gens qui sont vraiment
motivés et à partir de là si on arrive à
avoir un exemple qui marche puis un
deuxième puis un troisième
on peut ne payer clients le pari est en
passe d'être réussi
pastho ria le chef des maraîchers déjà
sur place pour vérifier la qualité du
compost et négocier les prix avec les
jeunes
[Musique]
ça et il faut un petit effort encore
parce que je vois encore certains m'ont
plastique
voilà je l'aï la queue qu'il faut
enlever parce que ça presque vallée peau
de tomate la boîte de commentry de la
valette la pile et puis là vous êtes
prêts à payer combien si c'est vraiment
fini
vous savez on avait dit au départ que
nous sommes prêts à payer le double du
prix parce que habituellement en fait 80
mille 4000
le chargement des zones à trier si ils
débarrassent ses ordures des plastiques
ferrailles des piles c'est exactement on
est prêt à payer le double prix si ce
centre de tri pilote parvient à
fonctionner son principe pourrait être
étendu à toute la ville et résoudre en
partie le problème des déchets de kindia
l'espoir d'une vie plus saine pour la
population changer le monde c'est pas
facile
c'est une belle ambition et je pense
qu'en effet comme disent les
altermondialistes d'autres mondes sont
possibles et je pense que dans notre
travail on y contribuer on montre qu'il
ya des alternatives
le modèle unique les dogmes ça marche
pas les expériences locales les
alternatives elles existent et il en
faut de plus en plus pour montrer qu'on
peut aller vers un monde un peu plus
social un peu plus humain tout en étant
économiquement viable au contribuer à
assainir la ville l'échéance de 2015
coopération atlantique guinée 44 propose
dès l'année prochaine
l'acquisition d'un tracteur et de dire
morte pour ramasser les ordures la mise
en place de trois centres de tri
sélectif la réalisation d'études en vue
d'aménager la décharge publique de
kindia
[Musique]
retour ayant pony le site de mangrove
dévasté sur la côte dîner m la récolte
de sel bat son plein sénégalais le
paysan poursuit son travail avec le bois
le feu s'est pas ni ses bacs en fer
blanc aujourd'hui à lyon toni ce n'est
pas vraiment un jour comme les autres
pour la première fois les producteurs
d'ici vont découvrir l'autre manière de
faire du sel nous sommes venus vous
apprendre comment utiliser les bâches
pour produire votre selle en quantité ça
sans couper du bois ni faire de la
cuisson au ténor tout pot et allisson
des ingénieurs agronomes guinéens ils
connaissent parfaitement la culture et
le savoir faire des paysans locaux
il travaille pour la dame l'organisation
third universel lo ng des paludiers de
guérande l'art de la bâche exigeant
terrain bien exposé à la chaleur et au
vent il faut nettoyer les aspérités
délimiter une heure de travail et
aplanir la surface pour un maximum de
rendement
pour convertir au sel solaire pas besoin
d'outils d'ailleurs ici personne n'en
possède
ensuite il suffit de verser la saumure
le soleil et le vent feront le reste
là tu ne comprends pas le bois n'est pas
le câble de boire s'il fait que
transporter seulement la terre s'arrêta
la nuit tu dois bien te propose le matin
tu viens tu es d'alte bâche du labour tu
fais le courage et puis à 12 à laudun
13h du bien tu fais du brass tu fais le
brassage et c'est fini il n'y a pas
d'avenir on entend de celle avec le feu
c'est une aberration et donc voit notre
mission c'est de faire en sorte que la
diffusion de ces techniques là qui sont
qui sont facilement appropriable quand
même par les producteurs se généralise
de façon à ce que demain
la guinée puisse produire du sel solaire
en grande majorité mais voilà c'est pas
du jour au lendemain que tout ça se met
en place
après quelques heures l'évaporation joue
son rôle
peu à peu les cristaux de sel
apparaissent et s'accumulent une journée
à laisser dorer au soleil et le soir
c'est la récole quelqu'un peut le tenir
ici et l'autre par là bas
allez-y fait claquer la vache
regarde moi c'est comme ça que vous
devez faire
et ensuite vous plier la bâche comme ça
et vous continuez en une journée avec 20
vaches on obtient plus de celle qu'en 24
heures de travail harassant
ininterrompue autour de deux bacs à feu
sénégalais a suivi toute l'opération il
à la fois des nouveaux convertis en ces
pages sont arrivés ce matin et que j'ai
participé à la pause
ma femme m'a demandé de tout laisser
tomber de revenir à la méthode
traditionnelle avec le feu car pour elle
ces bâches ne donnerai jamais de sel il
maintenant qu'elle voit ce que ces
belges peuvent produire c'est elle qui
m'encouragent elle me dit d'en acheter
davantage évitent désormais elle est
convaincue le sel solaires sur bâche un
autre énorme avantage il est meilleur
que le sel ignigène née du feu et de la
cuisson de sel et jeunes n'a aucune même
une petite goutte une petite quantité
diodes ça n'existe pas par contre le
seul solaire il ya déjà une certaine
quantité de naturelles qui existent de
santal différence c'est la meilleure
qualité c'est la meilleure qualité et
bien à consommer la névrose 1,6 est en
bonne santé
je travaille avec l'eau basse
[Musique]
16h40 face aux 30 basse paso je suis
travailleur plus blanc plus propre plus
écologique plus reposants
le sel sur bâche est la solution pour
préserver la mangrove et les hommes qui
y vivent
[Musique]
c'est un investissement sur l'avenir
c'est cette forêt de mangrove n'est pas
carabinée et à la guinée bien sûr c'est
elle qui la gère 7 mai à l'étang dans
l'écosystème planétaire donc je crois
que tout le monde l'a compris et c'est
pour ça que l'aide au développement et
si nécessaire parce que on peut pas
imaginer continuer à laisser se creuser
ce fossé entre laurent dessus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le château d'eau de l'afrique c'est le
surnom de la guinée ici pas de
sécheresse comme au sahel à kindia quand
arrive la saison des pluies en juillet
août
c'est le déluge les caniveaux déborde
charrie les déchets et d'énormes
problèmes de santé publique
[Musique]
carlo de kindia peut tuer la population
n'a pas conscience des risques
80% des kindia n'est continuent de
s'approvisionner aux sources en 2012 la
guinée a connu plus de 5000 cas de
choléra
112 personnes sont mortes de cette
bactérie véhiculées par l'eau sale et
les aliments mal nettoyé
[Musique]
pour s'attaquer au problème de l'eau
coopération atlantique guinée 44 travail
avec un retraité nantais michel maurice
ans cet ancien ingénieur chimiste est un
bénévole du développement il consacre
son temps et son savoir-faire à aider la
population de kindia michel maurice on a
mis au point un système de désinfection
des autres sources
[Musique]
quand je suis arrivé à la retraite
on a toujours du travail à faire emplois
de maison et je vais vous dire ce que
j'ai pensé au bout de deux mois au bout
de deux mois j'ai dit me morice on a
quoi tu sers à la société et c'est là
les primes ont atteint cet âge des faits
de cuir et un moment ça y est je me suis
trouvé embarqué âge et ma motivation
c'est d'avoir une population qui a accès
à l'eau potable
c'est un vrai problème puisque plus d'un
milliard d'individus aujourd'hui sur
d'autres planètes terre 1 n'ont pas
accès à l'eau potable
ces 2,2 milliards n'ont pas accès à
l'assainissement
alors c'est un problème grave parce au
moment où je vous parle il ya déjà
beaucoup de morts liés aux maladies
hydriques
ça c'est quelque chose de très important
ici l'espérance de vie les deux 47 48
heures et de la première cause de
mortalité est dédiée aux maladies
hydriques
le système maurisson c'est une bidouille
astucieuse pour chlorés les eaux de
sources à moindre coût du matériel de
récupération quelques tuyaux de pvc une
perfusion d'hôpital sert de goutte à
goutte pour verser juste ce qu'il faut
de chlore dans le réservoir
la maintenance est facile il suffit de
passer toutes les trois semaines pour
renouveler le bidon de chlore et l'eau
devient potable en permanence le système
maurice on a déjà fait ses preuves
quatre des sources parmi les plus
fréquentées sont équipés sur la commune
de kindia
les roues 20 mg de cloud résiduelles par
litre moi ça va satisfaire complètement
ça veut dire qu'avec ses rouge 0,20 mg
ils sont dans des bidons plus ou moins
propres ils peuvent se déplacer à la
case lots sera encore potable et comme
j'ai bien compris ils font deux tours
d'eau par jour
ça veut dire que sont toujours en eau
potable et moi c'est toute ma
satisfaction
et puis je vais vous dire à la vôtre je
vais déguster
selon madame la présidente
aujourd'hui je pense qu'elles témoignent
d'une réalité les gens ici sont en
meilleure santé
les diarrhées en particulier les maux de
ventre elle m'a même dit les gaz un il
n'y a plus c'est quelque chose de bon
avec le système maurisson l'eau est
traitée elle devient donc payante 100
francs guinéens le bidon de 20 litres un
centime d'euro c'est pas grand chose
elle en guinée c'est un bouleversement
des habitudes
pas toujours facile à faire admettre à
baisser c'est une question de culture
chez nous et ces bas les gens ils ont la
mentalité ils ont cette idée que l'os un
don de dieu donc il faut pas payer l'eau
donkey kong fait payer l'eau non
seulement il représentait satan ou agacé
c'est un dictateur il veut le faire
imposer quelque chose quoi donc déjà
pour ça il faut aller pas à pas leur
faire comprendre d'abord que l'eau
qu'ils buvaient avant mettez pas trop
tard et que maintenant et à deux il ya
une chose qui a été aménagé avec un
dispositif qui permet de cloud reinaudo
ils ont l' accès à une eau de qualité
loup en tant que telle n'est pas payante
c'est un bien public d'accord ça il ya
des débats au niveau international là
dessus mais le fait d'amener de l'eau
potable
le service de produire de transformer 2
d'amener l'eau potable à celui qui en a
besoin
ça c'est payant
la source coucou est la plus fréquentée
de kindia
elles alimentent chaque jour un bassin
de population de vingt mille personnes
près de 10% des habitants de la ville
alors la mise en place du système
maurice ont cette année a engendré de
vives discussions beaucoup accepte mal
que ce qui était gratuit hier deviennent
désormais payant surtout qu'en guinée le
revenu moyen ne dépasse pas 250 mille
francs guinéens soit 25 euros par mois
c'est un agent communal
emil touray qui se chargent des tournées
d'explication sur le terrain la commune
n'a jamais imposé de prix depuis deux
ans non ces algues à lauga avec les
usagers alors donnant vraiment les aïeux
qui qu'ils courent derrière cet
aménagement notamment d'accord y'a pas
de problème je contre 100 points sans
fond dans la bouche du guinéen ouais
quand même c'est pas trop peut-être
reconnaît quelqu'un qui a plus vraiment
aux accusés ça me fait confiance à vie
en passant par un de mes photos je vous
dis qu'il ya des parents ici qui peut
faire une zone même de journée sans
avoir de mille fois oui des talibans
si vous voulez qu'il était sûr après
c'est un match où on défend le paiement
de l'eau est une première difficulté
mais le système maurice on a également
ses propres limites
il n'est pas adapté à toutes les sources
de la ville ni à toutes les formes de
pollution
jonas pardo ingénieur des mines
fraîchement diplômés est venue de nantes
à la demande de guinée 44 pour évaluer
le dispositif en fait ici on est juste
en dessous de l'hôpital
si ça et ils ont fui ce leurs déchets
dans le sol alors on retrouve dans l'eau
pas mal de produits chimiques qui sont
qui sont peuvent pas être traitées par
par le chlore il est arrivé que les gens
disent oui on sent un goût de rouille
ont sans goût de médicament sans goût
d'alcool c'est des choses qu'on entende
la même si on mettait du club ça
permettrait pas de touriste le chocolat
non le chlore il est efficace pour ont
des pollutions d'origine fécale ou
organiques
il agit un peu comme un antibiotique
s'attaque aux bactéries pas aux
composants chimiques
l'idéal pour assurer un bon accès de
l'eau durable c'est le traitement
préventif et donc le la gestion
[Musique]
environnementale des points d'eau c'est
à dire contrôler le périmètre autour de
la résurgence de l'eau faire en sorte
que la nappe phréatique mais aucune
pollution de type fécales par le
déplacement des latrines dans des lieux
appropriés en aval des nappes
phréatiques éviter la l'utilisation
d'engrais chimiques
tout ce qui est à vulture autour des
points d'eau les hôpitaux qui
remplissent pas leurs déchets juste
juste une source
et avec un traitement préventif on a eu
nos qui est filtrée naturellement la
terre s'occupe de purifier l'eau de
manière naturelle plutôt que de rêver à
une solution technique miraculeuse
coopération atlantique guinée 44 va
s'atteler à un travail de fond dès
l'année prochaine
protéger les têtes de 15 nouvelles
sources et reboiser pour fournir une eau
de qualité à 15000 habitants
supplémentaires sensibiliser les kindia
n'est car payer une eau propre coûtera
beaucoup moins cher que des médicaments
une fois malade
[Musique]
à cent kilomètres de kindia retour en
brousse dans la région de télimélé où
l'unicef va construire de nouvelles
écoles pour encourager la scolarisation
des filles dans les villages concernés
les chantiers sont sur le point de
démarrer
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dung
elhadj mamadou bâ le représentant local
de l'administration scolaire est venu
annoncer la bonne nouvelle
asseyez vous asseyez vous merci
[Musique]
ce vieux sage 40 ans d'enseignement
rural derrière lui est un vrai showman
le parfaite orateurs de brousse si vous
voulez qu'une localité prospère
il faut que nos enfants étudient s'ils
étudient ils pourront devenir ministres
préfets sous préfets gouverneurs
président de la république pourquoi pas
mais tout cela dépend des études si
l'étude lire
ils pourront choisir leur avenir et cela
vous aidera ce projet ce n'est pas pour
vous donner de l'argent du riz ou des
moutons c'est pour scolariser vos
enfants pour qu'ils apprennent si les
enfants vont à l'école
notre village sortira des ténèbres s'ils
vont à l'école
notre localité sera connu c'est tout et
les mêlées qui sera prospère
c'est pour cela que les étrangers vont
tout faire pour qu'une nouvelle école
soit construite ici les populations
veulent bien scolarisés
elles ont le goût de l'école elles ont
invité leurs enfants passent elles ont
compris que ces populations que seuls
par le biais de l'éducation on peut
réussir
on peut libérer un pays avec un peuple
analphabète n'entend pas développer un
pays avec un peuple analphabète
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le village de ma b le chantier est
bien parti la nouvelle école commence
déjà à sortir de terre
comme pour toutes les écoles construites
par l'unicef dans la région le chantier
et participatif les parents d'élèves
contribuer aux travaux chacun à la
hauteur de ses moyens ou de ses
compétences
le menuisier local fait la découpe un
maçon du coin dirige le gros oeuvre en
impliquant les habitants on accélère la
prise de conscience en matière
d'éducation
julien harness le représentant de
l'unicef en guinée et kadiatou diallo
son adjointe sont venus sur place
inspecter l'avancée des travaux
[Applaudissements]
quand est-ce que vous avez couler le
béton
[Musique]
et il faut ça il faut le laisser encore
fraîche combien de temps comme c'est la
saison pluvieuse ont pu laisser pendant
une semaine comme ça je l'espère mais
j'ai un peu de construction et le
chantier me sentais bien organisés et la
qualité est là la mobilisation sociale
et colis jeudi vous dire que je suis un
peu inquiet avec l'arrivée des pluies
qui va être les délais et la qualité
alors qu'est ce que vous avez fait avant
de vous occuper de l'unicef en afrique
qu'est-ce que avant de d'être membre de
l'unicef deux représentants de nissan
vous avez fait quoi bon avant avant la
guinée j'étais en commun république
démocratique du congo
avant ça je suis passé je travaille un
peu avec unicef au liban et en indonésie
après le tsunami
bon avant s'est invitée dans le business
et avant ça dans l'armée l'armée le
business et après on s'occupe de
l'enfance dans les pays en voie de
développement ça parcours un peu
étonnant bon
c'est une notion de service service du
peuple je suis venu à nice est pour
continuer dans cet esprit et je trouve
ce que je cherchais l'école doit être
fini quatre mois plus tard pour la
rentrée scolaire à ma b le pari est en
passe d'être tenues et le cahier des
charges respecter notamment pour la
construction des latrines séparées pour
les filles un élément essentiel pour la
réussite du projet c'est de l'autre côté
la question des latrines ça peut être
décisif pour certaines personnes vous
allez à l'école ou pas ces recettes
elles décident
parce que surtout pour les filles elles
se sentent exposait d'utiliser le même
toit mais tout d'amener au même endroit
collègues absents
le projet de l'unicef ne vise pas
seulement à construire des bâtiments
l'ambition est aussi de réformer en
profondeur la pédagogie remettre
l'enfant au coeur du système éducatif
moi c'est julien salut bonjour
et toi comment tu t'appelles
tous à l'école ok des enfants mais coûte
bonne continuation parce qu'en guinée
on en est encore aux bonnets d'âne
version brousse qu'est ce que c'est que
d'abord c'est la dentition de gréver
bieber c'est toujours pour dire à
l'enfant car là on parle français
si tu parle la langue d'oc et loire la
langue nationale
grâce au ltte faire porter ça et les
enfants d'où alors justement que le trou
du cul ne réflétait l'afflux la langue
au front national très classe mais qui
parle aux français même s'ils étaient
mauvaises pratiques et le palais a même
en classe jusqu'à soldes arrivent à
faléa aux français les pit et qu'est ce
que vous allez changer les pédagogies
pour la canaliser c'est un peu comme la
pédagogie française mais deux trois
quatre décennies
c'est c'est une pédagogie qui est très
axé sur l'enseignant au centre de la
classe qui a la connaissance avec les
étudiants plus bas qui doit écouter et
répéter ce qu'on essaye de changer c'est
d'aller vers n'est la pédagogie actifs
c'est à dire c'est une pédagogie on
considère que l'enfant un moteur de son
propre éducation et donc il faut l'aider
à être curieux il faut l'aider à poser
des questions mais c'est difficile parce
que bon c'est on est en train de parler
avec d'une génération d'éducateurs qui
ont vécu ça autrement et qui bon qui
n'ont pas nécessité ne voit pas
nécessairement l'avantagent ou peut même
voir l'inconvénient dé
de telles approches une nouvelle
pédagogie pour de nouvelles écoles d'ici
l'unicef prévoit la construction de 18
établissements scolaires soit
l'ouverture de cinquante quatre classes
équipées en matériel pédagogique
l'objectif parvenir à scolariser 80 %
des enfants de la région de télimélé
contre 38% seulement à l'heure actuelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bientôt le démarrage de la
nouvelle saison de celles ayant connu le
site où la mangrove a été dévastée par
la coupe de bois
[Musique]
dix mois après notre dernier passage
nous revenons sur place pour voir si
l'utilisation des bâches progresse sur
la zone cette fois-ci alain courtel le
paludiers de guérande fondateur
d'universel et de la partie cela fait
près de sept ans qu'il n'est pas revenu
en guinée
il est même un peu désorienté en
arrivant mais il retrouve tout pout et
elle ses vieux complices de nos ong
locale la dame
bonjour très bien merci
vous défendez ici à lyon rhône il a
longtemps que j'avais pas refait du
terrain retrouvez ces visages ces hommes
et ces femmes qui qui qui qui se
bagarrent au quotidien pour pour
survivre et c'est eux monsieur mon
carburant
c'est eux qui me redonne la patate pour
aller pour aller convaincre que l'aide
au développement est nécessaire et que
surtout sur les projet aussi concret
aussi palpable que les nôtres donc voilà
de temps en temps il faut que je me
replonge au coeur de ce qui fait
ma motivation aujourd'hui haillan pony
alain est venu assister à la toute
première vente de bâches plastiques
organisée dans le village
un an après leur formation au sel
solaire les paysans du coin peuvent
enfin s'équiper pour attaquer la saison
de celle qui démarre dans quelques jours
les bâches sont céder à prix coûtant 40
mille francs guinéens pièce un peu moins
de 4 euros
je paye à lui là bas c'est combien déjà
et voici recompte bien alors quarante
mille c'est bon il n'y aura que six
acheteurs au total alors que lyon toni
contre 600 producteurs de sel en pleine
saison
succès mitigé pour la vente
en fait le prix même minime semble poser
problème
beaucoup de bâches n'ont pas trouvé
preneur alors certains essayent
d'obtenir les bâches gratuitement des
bâches cadeau mais le paludier breton ne
veux pas rentrer dans cette logique
au bout de quatre jours de production
quand ça marche bien
tu peux vendre pour plus de 40 mille
francs de 2 200
donc voilà une bâche en quatre jours
tulle a amorti tu peux la rembourser
voilà donc c'est pour ça que non c'est
bien ça je me trompe
ils savent mais nous moi je suis
producteur de sel comme toi fin donc on
peut pas faire n'importe quoi
un même si mon envie c'était de
distribuer comme ça vite
non non il faut être sérieux tout a un
prix ici il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de cadeaux forcément on peut pas faire
bâche cadeau parce que
c'est un système qui est
nécessite l'accompagnement en permanence
quoi donc après et puis le producteur
qui vous filent cette vache bon et pas
forcément bien utilisé derrière ou
utilisés à d'autres à d'autres fins pas
forcément perdu 7
donc ils pistent sais pas c'est pas une
solution pérenne
je pense que il ya moyen avec cette
technique là de pouvoir dégager des
revenus qui leur permettront demain de
pouvoir investir dans des cristallise
war en bâche
comme tous les exploitants comme tous
les agriculteurs il faudrait pas on peut
pas se substituer à l'économie agricole
en distribuant des bâches gratuitement
ça passe a pas de sens pour nous
une des solutions pour faire baisser le
prix des vaches que les paysans
s'organiser ce rebond
démonstration sur un autre lieu de
production du sel barry fanien une
localité initié au solaire il y a près
de dix ans depuis le site 7 entièrement
converti les producteurs du coin sont
autonomes et se passe de l'appui des ong
dans ce village pilote le débit de sel
atteint des niveaux industriels ici
grâce aux bâches c'est toute une
communauté qui a repris le contrôle de
son destin
[Musique]
dix ans après avoir lancé les bâches à
bari fania alain courtel revient mesurer
le chemin parcouru par ses amis guinéens
comme soriba un petit paysan devenu
aujourd'hui un entrepreneur de celle
solaire
il a désormais trois femmes et 10
enfants qui vont tous à l'école bons
fruits avec ces bâches il produit
presque 10 tonnes de sel par an deux
fois plus qu'avant au temps révolu des
paquets cuisson donc quand vous
organisez ici un baril fania pour avoir
les bâches peu ce que tu disais il ya un
groupement il ya un achat groupé
tu te chacun se débrouille quand je
passe te vois ta moko avant dans ma
langue au nombre de reculs un gamin
conakry en un sens à cette année nous
avons cotisé
tout le monde tous ceux qui veulent
travailler sur les bâches tout le monde
a cotisé l'argent de nos collègues a
fait un déplacement
on a pris sa transparence âge elle est
descendue chez le fournisseur pop et des
bâches et les envois tu veux montrer ton
temps qu'elle a passé à la baule mccarey
comme la plupart de ses collègues
ce producteur à positionner ces filtres
en batterie une innovation pour
recueillir plus de ce mur afin
d'alimenter plus de bâche qu'est ce que
tu penses de son installation la abc
c'est parfait n'est même pas pensé qu'on
pouvait mettre quatre temps qui en
batterie donc c'est que non seulement
ils se sont réappropriés mais ils ont
inventé félicitations des agriculteurs
prêts à défendre leur métier leurs
revenus et à sauvegarder leur
environnement comme les paludiers
français à guérande l'exemple d'une
solidarité réussi entre paysans du nord
et du sud
pour les années qui viennent l'objectif
d'universel est de faire reculer le sel
sur feu afin de régénérer la mangrove en
créant un réseau de distribution de
bâches pour faciliter
l'approvisionnement des producteurs et
en mettant en place un système de
microcrédit paysans pour encourager
l'achat des bâches
[Musique]
e
hu
en guinée la santé maternelle et
infantile est une urgence absolue
une maman guinéenne à 60 fois plus de
chances de décéder au cours de son
accouchement qu'une femme française le
taux de mortalité infantile est 25 fois
plus élevés qu'en france
[Musique]
à kindia
un homme a décidé de s'attaquer à ces
statistiques implacables
le docteur claude moncorgé est un ancien
président de médecins du monde
sa stratégie décentraliser la santé au
plus près des habitants
[Musique]
ce jour-là il supervise une formation en
direction des agents communautaires des
relais essentiels pour rapprocher les
structures de soins de la population
qu'est ce qu'ils apprennent contre ces
formations aujourd'hui à aujourd'hui
sont les jours de formation sur la
question du vih pour sensibiliser les
communautés y population donc ce sont
des agents communautaires qui sont
rattachés à chacun des centres de santé
oui que nous allons soutenir notre
programme c'est vraiment du travail de
sensibilisation qu'ils apprennent enfin
il revoit les thèmes sur lesquels ils
sont censés pouvoir reparler transmettre
un message
une vingtaine d'agents communautaire
formés et diplômés pour promouvoir la
santé au coeur des quartiers de kindia
et des villages alentours
claude moncorgé dirige l'opal ce
l'organisation panafricaine de lutte
pour la santé à ses côtés goya galdos la
représentante de l'association en guinée
l'opal ce une petite ong spécialisée
dans l'amélioration de la santé
maternelle et infantile
rendez vous à l'hôpital de kindia un
lieu que claude moncorgé connaît bien
avec médecins du monde il y a supervisé
la réhabilitation de la maternité
quinze ans plus tard le french doctor
revient sur les lieux
c'est un beau bébé 1 2 vient de claquer
une complication qui l'a kembs la 3g
n'est pas celle qu'elle veut aider les
injures
elle est venue pour le pansement
voilà grosso pourrait bien si tout va
bien d'accord bon c'est bien c'est bien
quand ça se passe bien comme ça j'ai été
sensibilisée à la médecine ans en
afrique lorsque j'avais 25 ans à peu
près et que j'étais en cours au début
juste avant mon internat et je pense que
ça n'a même si je m'en suis pas rendu
compte à l'époque n'a pas été étranger à
1 cette ouverture que m'a donné ce
séjour de quelques mois en afrique
et puis ensuite la période 94 95
vraiment du rwanda mme plonger
totalement dans ces questions là puisque
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps et puis et
puis après j'ai eu du mal à réintégrer
une activité le praticien hospitalier
qui certes est très noble et
merveilleusement enrichissante mais que
j'ai vécu à travers ces expériences
avant comme un petit peu étouffante
bonjour
et au bon moment
[Musique]
m
lauren st lô dana maison
les villes avec travail pour l'eau j'ai
finalement désarmant on sait que la
mentalité et la mortalité
néonatale dans des pays comme la guinée
sont élevées sans anormalement élevé et
c'est en grande partie parce que les
femmes où viennent pas du tout non pas
du tout accès à des structures de soins
pendant leur grossesse dont qui
accouchent chez elle où viennent trop
tard aujourd'hui il ya moins de 50 % des
femmes enceintes qui viennent consulter
une structure de soins en grossesse
donc on voudrait arriver à plus de 80%
pour cela l'ol j'ai française va
concentrer son action à l'extérieur de
l'hôpital dans les centres de santé des
dispensaires disséminés à la périphérie
de kindia comme celui de wendy ce petit
centre prend en charge 20% de la
population de la ville
cinquante six mille visites par an dans
des conditions précaires
[Applaudissements]
ouais
ici est-ce que c'est facile est ce que
là tout ce qu'il faut pour travailler
mais c'est libye
j'ai malgré tout le côté n'a pas les
poyas pas les plateaux ya pas les
prévoir donc si on fait de tout ici les
accouchements mais aussi des premiers
soins les vaccinations et le suivi des
grossesses neuf mois 1,7 cm la femme en
neuf mois de grossesse
j'essaie de parler pour voir la
présentation c'est la présentation
céphalique c'est la présentation
céphalique
l'enfant se prennent pas la tête
[Musique]
et allez bdc à la bourse du caire est à
l'enfant est né vivant
cette hausse est à votre écoute et vous
pouvez voir sa peine tout être humain
le docteur diallo et le chef du centre
de gondi depuis cinq ans état des lieux
c'est une salle tout la commande est
tous là c'est très vétuste très métis
c'est nous qui avons cherché des bois en
vie des ménages y ait tapé koulou on
peut on peut vraiment devenir des soins
dans cette vie dans ces conditions sous
licence c'est vraiment difficile
ce microscope l'aïd est de caen a mal
fait parler ils étaient là avant goût
avant c'est la débrouille toi on va
continuer sa vie ça c'est valable si la
guinée fait partie des pays les plus en
retard pour des raisons politiques vous
savez qu'il ya eu deux fois de dictateur
dans 50 ans qui ont chacun eu 25 ans de
mandat c'est un pays qui a beaucoup de
ressources mais qui a été gérée en tout
cas la centaine et paul propres est une
priorité
donc il est un peu logique
enfin il est dans la logique
d'organisation telle que la nôtre de
d'aller vers les pays qui sont les moins
bien lotis et où il ya le moins des
l'extérieur
le centre de wendy fait partie des
priorités de l'opal ce lot ong et
finance les travaux de réhabilitation du
dispensaire écouter ce qu'on veut c'est
que dans chaque sens me sentais bien
laboratoire qu'il soit à peu près à
équiper d'abord réhabiliter et ensuite
et qui vous fournira les équipements de
base c'est on a vu un microscope pour
chaque laboratoire un mois un appareil
pour mesurer l'hémoglobine pour chercher
les femmes enceintes sont pas là n'est
mis la glycine et aussi pour réussir sa
mission
l'opal ce intervient aussi à l'extérieur
de la ville dans les postes avancés en
brousse
à une heure de route de la ville la
localité de rognard compris
sous le manguier ce jour là c'est la
stratégie avancée
une campagne de vaccination pour tous
les enfants du village on a vu que le
nôtre ce qui était assez éloignée le
village encore plus éloigné les centres
de santé des os d'animaux ici des
monuments et encore le poste de santé en
visite là il est à 25 kilomètres de
couloirs la dose à 70 km donc le but de
falla toute la démarche c'est de le
couvrir au maximum et d'aller au maximum
vers les populations
nous comprenons bien que ces familles là
vont pas aller jusqu'à jusqu'à combien
elles peuvent pas faire un hacker donc
le but c'est d'aller c'est ce qu'on
appelle un stratégie avancée c'est
d'aller vers la création et vers les
communautés qui sont par ailleurs tout à
fait éveillé au besoin d'attention les
attendent
est ce que vous allez pouvoir apporter
beaucoup
nous ce qu'on veut apporter c'est qu'à
partir de cette campagne là des messages
de vaccinations nécessaires
ces populations là soit bien conscient
qu une femme enceinte c'est mieux
qu'elle aille au point de sentir les
enfants base a été faire un petit peu si
ce qu'un si grand si l'on respire et ça
évite au centre de santé pour améliorer
au delà de l'agitation les stratégies
avancées sont souvent l'unique contacts
entre les médecins et la population qui
n'a pas de moyens de transport mais le
territoire à couvrir est tellement vaste
qu'il faudra deux ou trois ans avant de
revoir un même village
alors il faut profiter de l'occasion
pour repérer les pathologies à risque
si on vous dit qu'il ya un cadre assez
banal et qui doit être opéré parce que
si elle est un jour titre anglais à ce
moment là c'est très dangereux qui c'est
une cause et une urgence chirurgicale
nam indédit biologique mi6 et compliqué
serez donc pas ici de voir avec le
directeur de l'hôpital pour koné d'opter
quels seraient les moyens de faire
opérer la police avec le moins de points
possible une semaine plus tard la petite
kadiatou est prise en charge à l'hôpital
régional de kindia
[Musique]
l'opération s'est très bien passée
le coeur de métier de l'opal ce lot
angie de claude moncorgé c'est la lutte
contre le sida en guinée près de 10000
gamins de moins de 14 ans sont touchés
par le virus
le pays compte soixante mille orphelins
du sida pourtant les solutions existent
en france
la transmission de la mère à l'enfant du
vih a quasiment disparu
si on ne fait rien une femme enceinte
séropositive va transmettre le virus à
son enfant dans environ 40% des cas
pendant la grossesse pendant
l'accouchement et pendant l'allaitement
et que si on les traite correctement
comme on fait dans nos pays du nord ce
tout transmission est quasiment annulé
donc l'impact est très très fort en
termes de santé publique avec des moyens
sérieux mais par pas énorme
on peut annuler éliminer la transmission
de la mère à l'enfant du vih
soignez les mamans séropositives avec
des antirétroviraux pour sauver les
bébés et enrayer l'épidémie de sida un
petit miracle qui a du mal à démarrer en
guinée à kindia le centre de santé de
manquer pas en centre-ville est le seul
à pratiquer le dépistage du sida chez
les femmes enceintes et à leur offrir
des traitements pour prévenir la
transmission de la mère à l'enfant
son enfant au début j'étais très
inquiète
mais ici je suis très bien suivi on me
donne des médicaments et on s'occupe
bien de moi donc là ça va beaucoup mieux
je suis très optimiste
est ce que la peur d'être rejeté par son
village quelqu'un l'a prenait la main
oui j'ai peur une autre femme de mon
village a été répudiée pour ça chez nous
si tu est séropositive
tu es mis à l'écart tu es une paria mais
ma propre famille ne veut plus approcher
la stigmatisation en afrique c'est la
mort sociale à kindia à peine 15% des
femmes testées positives ont le courage
de revenir au centre de santé pour être
suivi
l'immense majorité préfère se faire
oublier c'est pour ces femmes et leurs
enfants que l'eau palce se bat
oui j'accepte et dépistage parce qu'au
fond au fond pourquoi parce qu'ils
n'osent pas dire non qui sont face à une
autorité médicale qui dit il faut vous
faire dépister
et après il est de même pas chercher les
résultats qui disparaissent donc tout le
travail dans une ville pourtant qui est
pas la dernière ville du pays et qui est
pas au fin fond de la brousse qui
simplement à 1h30 2h de conakry
c'est de faire en sorte de faire
comprendre que ce faire comprendre que
cette maladie c'est une maladie qui on
peut traiter qui vous permet d'être
enceinte qui vous permet d'avoir des
enfants qui va être avoir une vie
normale donc un énorme travail en amont
de faire au niveau des affaires les
communautés d'ici 2015
l'opal ce va rénover équiper et former
le personnel de 14 centres de santé sur
kindia et de 62 postes avancés en
brousse soit un meilleur accès aux soins
pour soixante mille femmes en âge de
procréer
l'objectif éliminer la transmission du
vih de la mère à l'enfant
[Musique]
voici venu le moment d'un ultime
déplacement pour cette année 2012
direction l'intérieur des terres vers la
préfecture de télimélé où l'unicef mène
son programme de construction d'écoles
dans la localité de mab et le 3 octobre
c'était la fin des vacances le début
d'une nouvelle histoire pour les enfants
du village
finies aussi les cours dans l'ancienne
école en ruines
parce qu'ici le pari a été tenu la
rentrée des classes a lieu dans un
bâtiment flambant neuf et ça change tout
pour la petite aïssatou notamment pour
vous souvenez l'an dernier elle ne
fréquentait pas les cours faute de
moyens aujourd'hui c'est sa première
rentrée avec un kit fourni par l'unicef
pour elle et tous ses camarades de
classe
[Musique]
je
l'école a été livrée juste à temps pour
la rentrée
le mobilier est fraîchement vernis et
les artisans termine les finitions
pendant les cours mais ce n'est pas
grave parce qu'elle m'avait désormais le
tableau noir est vraiment noir et avec
sa taille xxl tout le monde peut suivre
la leçon sans problème
ici maintenant tous les enfants ont
droit à une scolarité normale
même quand ils sont issus d'une famille
démunie comme aïssatou qui doit encore
apprendre à surmonter sa timidité
après toutes ces années son cours il te
plait la nouvelle école c'est pourquoi
je suis contente
est ce que nous un peu
je suis contente pour plein de choses
les boucles un de choses comme quoi et
bien en venant ici je vais devoir être
utile à moi même julien harness le
patron de l'unicef en guinée est venu
s'assurer que la construction est bien
conforme au cahier des charges
c'est quoi comme moi
et notamment les latrines séparées pour
les filles et les garçons un aspect
essentiel pour encourager les jeunes
filles après compter les cours est-ce
qu'on va marquer filles et garçons
comment ça c'est la vie de l'autre côté
ça les gars sont ok mais avec des
dessins à quelques détails près tout est
en ordre
le chantier de mme abbey a tenu ses
promesses les représentants de l'unicef
ont tenu à rencontrer madame barry la
maman d'aïssatou pour comprendre ce qui
l'avait convaincu d'envoyer ses enfants
en cours elles ne gagnent pas plus
d'argent qu'avant mais au village
le nouveau bâtiment semble avoir déjà
changé les consciences c'est qui qui
vint l'école faire le bonheur de fallait
qu'on sait aïssa tour
et puis son petit frère mamadou ali qui
a pris sa décision et quand il commit
jeux sont mes deux filles aînées
kadiatou et binta qui m'ont beaucoup
encouragée
elles m'ont demandé de laisser les
petits fréquenté l'école et monte
affirmé qu'elle allait m'aider pour
compenser tous les frais qui restent à
notre charge
moi et ma soeur binta on s'est mis au
travail
on essaie de mettre un peu de sou de
côté on se cotise pour soutenir nos
petits frères et soeurs et les envoyer
en cours nous les grandes
nous n'avons pas eu la chance d'aller à
l'école moi je ne suis pas instruits je
ne souhaite pas que les petits subissent
le même sort qu'ils sont ignorants eux
aussi j'étais très impressionné de voir
les deux filles aînées qui étaient prêts
à mettre leur temps et leur énergie de
la danse la décision ça vient bon ben ça
vaut le coup d'investir en vasseur on va
se donner
donc ce que je retire de ça c'est qu'il
faut qu'on travaille sur la qualité
parce que si on fait un beau bâtiment
mais que les enfants ils apprenaient
pour l'investissement de kadiatou et
binta cela n'aurait pas servi
mais ce qui est un marché à mme abbey
n'a pas forcément réussi partout
direction bape et l'autre village qui
attendait sa nouvelle école
ici aussi c'est la rentrée le chantier
est au point mort un problème de terrain
les premières fondations ont été
abandonnés pour un autre site un peu
plus bas la fabrication des briques
démarre tout juste
on est loin du compte du coup les élèves
débutent l'année dans l'ancienne école
dans des conditions encore plus précaire
qu'avant car beaucoup de parents
attendaient le nouveau bâtiment et ont
inscrit leurs enfants en masse
heureusement l'unicef a prévu
suffisamment de fournitures et la
maîtresse maintient le moral des troupes
je suis sûr que dans deux mois le
bâtiment sera fini ça s'est saoulé
certaines des sacs
on a mis les simon les seniors y aller
faire donc les graves et d'or les
chantiers dorin bilguissa qui espéraient
un nouveau professeur pour le cours
élémentaire devra donc encore patienter
tu as vu le la construction d'écoles
mais avait pas fini qu'est ce que tu en
penses c'est un petit peu décevant quand
même moi je croyais qu'on allait faire
la rentrée dans le nouveau bâtiment mais
apparemment ça ne sera pas le cas je ne
connais pas les raisons du retard mais
j'espère que ça ne durera pas trop
longtemps
en fait le site de bap et cumule les
difficultés
ici pas de sable et très peu d'eau pas
facile de tenir les délais du chantier
dans de telles conditions seraient
travaux ya une partie de problèmes d'eau
m'est imparti
[Applaudissements]
les techniciens ce n'était pas bon ils
ont reconstruit l'école là-bas en pente
qui n'était peut-être pas une bonne
solution technique
donc après réflexion on a changé ma
pensée c'est là bas c'est le lieu est
mieux mais bon sa nécessité de recreuser
pour faire les fondations qui nous a
retardé les partenaires de l'unicef se
sont engagés à terminer l'école d'ici la
fin décembre
en faisant venir du matériel et des
artisans depuis kindia la grande ville
pour accélérer les choses
nous serons là pour nous assurer du
respect de cette nouvelle échéance
et vous en rendre compte car nous n'en
sommes qu'au début de l'histoire
accompagné pendant les quatre ans qui
viennent avec votre soutien aux fonds
kindia plus l'effort d'éducation en
faveur des petites filles
un défi à relever ensemble pour aider la
population de kindia et sa région a
trouvé son chemin vers le développement
[Musique]
camus
le silicone
[Musique]
maillé ni la carlingue
elena quasiment